le verdict de la cour de sûreté de
l'état
simeoni condamné à cinq ans de prison
dont deux avec sursis
italie démocratie chrétienne est parti
communiste face à face
valéry giscard d'estaing à londres
l'accueil cordial
vaincre l'insécurité dans le métro par
une police spéciale c'est le dossier de
ce journal
colas guerlain fauconnier les
souffrances des hommes dans la transat
en exclusivité les premières images
les voici ses premières images il a
traversé ou presque car sur la carte
terre-neuve ce n'est pas très loin de la
côte américaine mais pour alain colas
arrivé à saint-jean de terre-neuve c'est
tout de même la mesure d'une déception
voile déchirée par l'ouragan gréement
abîmé le merveilleux 72 mètres de colas
a été contraint à l'escale avant
l'arrivée à newport
cela fera quelques heures de retard en
plus de retard sur tabarly bien sûr
pendant que colas doit réparer
fébrilement son bateau on sait que la
dernière fois que tu as berly a été
repéré il avait près de trois jours d'
avance et fidèle à son image de mara
silencieux tabarly pendant ce temps n'a
toujours pas touché à sa radio à l'heure
actuelle il est peut être déjà devant
newport
on ne le saura que quand il sortira du
brouillard pour franchir la ligne
d'arrivée
le vent est faible à newport on attend
et à terre-neuve pendant sept ans cola
va appareiller de nouveau
un terre-neuve après cola voici
l'arrivée du grand trois-mâts divan
fauconnier l'ancien vendredi 13 en
remorque en piteux état les voiles perdu
en remorque d'un chalutier soviétique et
à bord il ya aussi jean yves terlat lui
n'a plus de bateaux du tout son trimaran
désintégré par la tempête et par le
fonds au milieu de la tente l'atlantique
et tandis qu'on attend ce soir la
victoire presque certaine est imminente
de tabarly terre-neuve contemple ce
rendez-vous des perdants mais quand on
songe à ce qu'ils ont vécu
parce qu'ils ont subies depuis le 5 juin
sur l'atlantique déchaînée par l'ouragan
il faut bien le dire pour cette transat
76 même les perdants sont admirables
et
bonsoir cinq ans d'emprisonnement dont
deux avec sursis pour le docteur edmond
simeoni
c'est le verdict de la cour de sûreté de
l'état pour ses coïnculpés des peines
allant de un à quatre ans de prison avec
sursis depuis 14h30
quelques 200 corse et sympathisants
étaient groupés et attendait les
mouvements dans le hall du palais de
justice
ce n'est qu'à 17h30 que le verdict a été
prononcé un grand flux ans a suivi puis
dans la salle d'audience s'est élevé
l'hymne corse repris par tous ceux qui
se trouvaient sur les marches dans un
climat de tension qui aurait pu
provoquer des incidents graves
les avocats du docteur simeoni ont dû
intervenir pour calmer les manifestants
si on tacleur accepté de se disperser
peu de flâneurs ce soir place saint
nicolas à bastia seulement des hommes et
des femmes des jeunes qui passent de
groupe 1 go de plus en plus nombreux on
se rassemble pour dire son amertume ou
sa colère les drapeau à tête de maure
sont ressortis défiant des forces de
l'ordre police et armée qui reste pour
l'heure discrète aux terrasses des cafés
les touristes reçoivent les tracts
annonçant la condamnation
tout se passe comme si la fièvre aux
passionnés des militants autonomie se
déclarer publiquement
mais plus encore que cette réaction de
dépit de violence contenue
les amis du docteur simeoni m'ont dit
leur profonde déception devant ce qu'ils
appellent l'incompréhension du pouvoir
ce soir a encore envie que la coupe est
pleine
il me semble bien qu'il ne faudra pas
grand chose pour qu'elle déborde
cet arrêt de condamnations prononcées
par la cour de sûreté de l'état est un
geste politique dont lac léman soulève
autant de problèmes crâne est apaisé
clémence parce que le docteur civaux
unis avaient été tout de même présenté à
la cour de sûreté sous 4 inculpation qui
réclamait théoriquement sa tête le sens
de la justice démontré par cette cour si
souvent suspectés a permis au docteur
simoni de faire du prétoire de paris une
tribune d'où pendant six semaines il a
expliqué les problèmes de la corse et
des corses
edmond simeoni est devenu une sorte d'
interlocuteur pour paris de catalyseur
de symboles de rassembleur si vous me
permettez ce mot barbare des énergies et
des mouvements en corse
un homme dont l'analyse le sens des
responsabilités le jugement politique en
somme le poids serait sans doute sur
place forte utile pour continuer et
renforcer le nouveau dialogue établi
entre paris et la corse par exemple j'y
pense lors de consultations électorales
mais edmond s'il veut ni en prison peut
difficilement assumer cette
représentativité
l'alternative est difficile si on le
garde trop longtemps en prison il
devient une sorte de martyrs qui fait
naître ou durcir des oppositions
si on le libère trop tôt il peut
apparaître en corse comme s'étant dit
ont rapproché les tests de paris en
outre la politique et leur passion ne
doivent pas faire oublier aux corses que
deux hommes sont morts en faisant tout
simplement leurs devoirs on rit parfois
un peu de ce genre d'expression mais il
faut admettre ce square le sort de ces
deux hommes la justice qu'on leur devait
passe une nouvelle fois derrière la
raison d'état c'est à dire le retour au
calme dans la communauté
le docteur simioni y pensait peut-être
cet après-midi en regardant ce qui
chantait pour le soutenir
38,7 pour cent pour les
démocrates-chrétiens 34,4 pour cent pour
les communistes
hier pendant la campagne électorale on
avait un peu oublié la crise économique
en italie au profit du choix imposé le
pci parti numéro un où la démocratie
chrétienne championne de l'occident
alors aujourd'hui au vu des résultats
rien n'est résolu qui va pouvoir
gouverner est sorti et l'italie
l'enlisement la démocratie chrétienne a
retrouvé le même nombre de voix qu'en
1972 sans raz-de-marée les communistes
ont nettement confirmé leur poussée les
seuls perdants les petits partis hier
soir les résultats des élections sont
déjà connus on sait qu'il ya une sorte
de miracle et que la démocratie
chrétienne à retrouver les voix des
élections générales de 1972 et pourtant
il n'y avait que des communistes dans la
rue enthousiaste c'est que le miracle
démocrate chrétien n'a pas empêché le
parti communiste de gagner 7 % de voix
par rapport aux élections générales de
curieusement on pouvait fêter deux
victoires à rome
celle des communistes et celle des
démocrates chrétiens n'ont jamais nié la
france chez des tiers
et comme ils ont fait des victimes en
allégeant qu'on volait bas l'allier on a
toujours dit non
vince young réduire au seul jusque là
n'a pas été rejoints tiennent à
maintenir les positions de 72 leur moto
et ça c'est humain ce n'est pas ce que
nous voulons c'est de gagner un peu
moins d'accord je vais bientôt un peu
plus alors précisément en quoi ces
élections vont elles résoudre la crise
politique italienne maintenant qu'elles
peuvent être la suite et comment vont
s'entamer les conversations et des
forêts redd plus difficile la cape il
s'agit de puits du gisement pas vide et
que se crée aussi parce que le parti
socialiste dans cette situation n'est
pas le chien affirmé une fonction que
nous croyons nécessaire
shell et ça ça fait peser une difficulté
pour plus grande entre l'association
italienne alors une trace dans le sud
chrétien qui a mené cette lutte dans ces
termes frontale qui doit dire qu'est ce
qui se propose de faire vous avez eu que
mais même dans ces journées des motions
et tran donc de la tête épaule nous
parlons nécessité de l'apport les forces
politiques mais je me suis de dien et
il nous souhaitons qu est l autre côté
il y avait même sens responsabilités
alors on pourrait trouver les accords
nécessaires limité pour face à la
nécessité d'urgence les la situation
italienne
la balle est donc lancée dans le camp de
la démocratie chrétienne mais si l'anti
communisme était le thème principal des
démocrates chrétiens pendant la campagne
électorale
est ce que cela engage réellement
l'après élection il ya là qu'est
toujours dans les systèmes démocratiques
si je me rappelle bien nous avons déjà
parlé des saints à bâle les élections
c'est à dire l'état du système
démocratique
tous les partis qui prend pas au système
on les voit pas les droits les devoirs
des par les laisser confronter avec les
autres partis
même des oppositions même les partis de
l'opposition
notre secrétaire général haqqani a
toujours répété par confusion entre
majorité et opposition
c'est la règle de systèmes démocratiques
mais c'est à landelles a respecté à ce
que les aides en 16 ans
c'est à dire que par exemple si sur un
point précis vous aviez besoin des voix
communistes à l'assemblée députés
voulaient refuseriez pas non non nous
durant à l'achat à la recherche d'une
formule capable d'avoir tous les cons
sans les votes suffisante pour ces
maintenir vivante et opératif s'il y
aura d autre part et les communes par
exemple qui ajustent leurs bottes
alors ça ne change rien alors finalement
pensez vous que la démocratie chrétienne
pourra gouverner après ces élections
nous allons capable c'est évident c'est
arithmétique la démocratie chrétienne ne
pourra pas gouverner seul
mais les alliés éventuels les
socialistes sont traumatisés traumatisé
par une perte de voix de l'ordre de 3%
et exige une participation des
communistes au pouvoir
les problèmes du pays et reste il faut
résoudre ces problèmes et parti
socialiste voulait seulement ça qui les
problèmes du pays qui sont très graves
problèmes économiques les problèmes
sociale soit finalement résolue les
réformes
enfin réalisé alors qu'est-ce qui va
proposer la démocratie chrétiens alors
c'est un problème entre les partis
communistes et la démocratie chrétiens
la chose qui a changé c'est ça qui est
avant tout le monde disait c'est aux
socialistes de décider maintenant tout
le monde voit très bien que c'est à la
démocratie créteil au parti communite la
responsabilité de donner solution à
cette situation
rome aura peut être un maire communiste
en effet il faut savoir qu'à côté du
renouvellement de la chambre des députés
et du sénat les italiens votaient aussi
pour le renouvellement des municipalités
alors je viens de recevoir l'instant les
résultats pour hommes ce sont des
résultats partiels mais ils donnent le
parti communiste en tête quand viendrait
donc s'ajouter aux nombreuses
municipalités qui ont déjà des maires
communistes
peut-être vous vous en souvenez quelques
semaines avant les élections italienne
le chef de la diplomatie américaine
avait mis en garde l'europe contre
l'arrivée des communistes au pouvoir
alors on attendait la réaction de
washington le président ford se félicite
du résultat
legault un gouvernement démocratique en
italie
et préserver les partis non communistes
et non fascistes ont la majorité a dit
le président américain
quant à monsieur kissinger qui est à
paris depuis deux jours ils participent
à la réunion des ministres de l'osce et
des oeufs il a été prudent en commentant
les résultats des élections en italie
pour lui rien n'est changé et toutes les
hypothèses sont permises les élections
italiennes n'ont pas fondamentalement
changé et résolu le problème pose au
printemps c'est à dire soit que les
réformes nécessaires en italie seront
entreprises par les partis démocratiques
soit qu'elles seront entreprises avec la
participation des communes
je crois qu'une possibilité existe
encore de former une coalition des
partis démocratiques
c'est à dire ni communiste ni fasciste
puisque c'est parti démocratique ont
réuni 56 % des voix maintenant les
partis politiques italiens doivent
choisir la voie qu'ils veulent faire
conseil des ministres avancé d'un jour
écourtée ce matin en raison des quatre
jours de visite officielle du président
de la république en angleterre en vie
tant le palais de l'elysée monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing fait remarquer
qu'il était le premier chef d'état
français à se rendre à londres depuis
l'adhésion de la grande-bretagne marché
commun c'est l'occasion at il dit de
réexaminer nos rapports pour tenir
compte de la nouvelle solidarité
historiques entre la france et la grande
bretagne
lorsqu'on est simple citoyen français
l'angleterre déjà dépayse alors que dire
des fastes de la monarchie
lorsque la reine d'angleterre soit
monsieur madame valérie giscard
d'estaing dès leur arrivée ont pu en
goûter tout le cérémonial
rien n'apparaît accompagnée du duc
d'edimbourg alors que le train fait son
entrée dans victoria steicher il est
12h30 près précise la souveraine
souhaite en france est la bienvenue à
ses hôtes avant de se rendre vous allez
le voir dans un instant avant de se
rendre sur l'esplanade devant la gare
pour les honneurs militaires
le président français accompagné du duc
d'edimbourg passe en revue un
détachement des welsches ward la garde
d'honneur de la reine
et puis c'est le départ en carrosse vers
buckingham palace
valéry giscard d'estaing prend place aux
côtés de la reine dans le premier
carrosse blanc giscard d'estaing est
accompagné par le duc d'edimbourg dans
le seau le spectacle est vraiment
splendide ou en couleur sous un soleil
magnifique
le trajet est assez court entre la gare
victoria et buckingham mais la foule est
très dense
il n'y a pas eu de visite officielle
d'un président français depuis 15 ans
ici en angleterre depuis le général de
gaulle en 1960
très exactement et de l'avis général il
y a longtemps qu'un chef d'état étranger
il a reçu un accueil aussi spontanée
aussi chaleureux tant de la part de la
famille royale que de celle du peuple
britannique
c'est ici au palais de buckingham qui
est le palais royal officiel que
résideront le président français madame
giscard d'estaing pendant ces quatre
jours de visite
premier geste de ce voyage n'est
officiel mais tout à fait amicale le
cadeau surprise des îles d'elizabeth ii
à valéry giscard d'estaing un chien un
magnifique labrador noir qui s'appelle
sandringham samba
bien entendu les fastes de la cour les
carrosses l'apparat même le protocole
c'est la grande bretagne éternelle c'est
la tradition mais bien sûr il y à
l'autre grande bretagne celle de la
crise économique celle du marché commun
une grande bretagne qui sera évidemment
extrêmement présente pipe au long de ce
voyage c'est la première fois que valéry
giscard d'estaing rencontre
officiellement ici à londres le nouveau
premier ministre travailliste james
callaghan dont l'objectif prioritaire
est le redressement économique avant de
songer à jouer un rôle plus actif au
sein de la communauté europe et valéry
giscard d'estaing va essayer de le
convaincre de renverser sa proposition
en expliquant qu'il n'y a pas de salut
hors deux langues dès hier soir dans une
interview à la télévision à la bbc il a
insisté sur la volonté sa volonté de
resserrer les liens franco britannique
pendant ce voyage dans le cadre européen
selon le modèle des relations franco
allemands mais il faudra aussi
convaincre james callaghan qu'ils se
contenteraient volontiers de la
situation présente que l'accélération de
la construction européenne est une bonne
chose c'est l'objectif numéro un de ce
voyage jacques chirac est actif et est
loyal c'est ce que monsieur valéry
giscard d'estaing avait confié à jacques
chancel
la semaine dernière le premier ministre
pendant ces prochaines 48 heures
s'appliquera à illustrer ces jugements
actifs oui même à 100 à l'heure le
marathon se tait mais se terminera sur
le plateau du journal d'antenne 2 où
monsieur jacques chirac
demain soir répondra en direct aux
questions de plusieurs journalistes
mais dans la journée de demain hiller a
prononcé un discours sur le 7e plan à
l'assemblée nationale ce soir sur le
thème de la liberté
il s'adressera aux jeunes de l'udps et r
après avoir ce matin assister au conseil
des ministres accompagné le président à
orly est passé l'après midi à
l'assemblée nationale
et c'est là que tout en restant actif le
voici loyal réunissant les trois groupes
de la majorité
il leur a demandé de voter à l'unanimité
le texte sur les plus values je ne vous
le demande pas cela pour moi a dit le
premier ministre
mais dans l'intérêt de toute la majorité
cela faisait longtemps que l'on n'avait
pas vus ensemble réunis dans la même
salle les députés les trois groupes de
la majorité
jacques chirac a saisi cette occasion
pour prôner l'unanimité dans le vote du
texte sur les plus belles je ne vous
demande pas cela pour moi mais dans
l'intérêt de la majorité a expliqué le
premier ministre
une preuve de désintéressement de la
part de monsieur chirac ou un
avertissement sans frais à ces mêmes
députés au choix cela dit le premier
ministre a également annoncé qu'au cours
d'un déjeuner avec les trois présidents
de groupe
il avait élaboré un compromis sur six
dispositions déjà votées et pour
lesquelles le gouvernement demande d'une
seconde délibération un compromis qui ne
satisfait pas plus qu'auparavant ce qui
dans la majorité reste résolument
opposés au texte
le problème pour eux aujourd'hui c'est
qu'ils doivent se compter pour l'instant
il y encore une trentaine de députés qui
ne voteront pas pour et de loi et une
quinzaine d'autres qu'ils fassent
tiendront pourquoi vous dit pour
l'instant que je ne tiens pas leur
bulletin de vote
tu es comme il y en avait 100 au départ
et que nous nous retrouvons une leçon
une trentaine maintenant je me demande
encore si d'ici cette nuit que ce projet
de loi sera votée il n'y en a pas
quelques-uns qui est il et sont tombés
en cours de route
et si vous n'avez pas l'investiture
présidentielle qu'est ce que vous ferez
ce monsieur là je le prends d'appui que
considérons que je n'ai pas droit à
l'investiture présidentielle je l' ai
déjà dit je le répète je me contenterai
de l'investiture hectares dont les
couloirs de l'assemblée aujourd'hui
beaucoup de murmurer dans l'hémicycle la
reprise d'un débat qui ne devrait se
terminer que tard dans la nuit d'ores et
déjà à l'amendement qui tendait à
renvoyer purement et simplement le texte
en commission a été repoussé le scrutin
est révélateur du malaise qui règne
parmi les députés
250 voix contre mais 207 sur 4,9 pour
cent de hausse pour les renault en 1977
elles seront mises en vente à partir de
juillet ce n'est qu'un début toutes les
autres marques françaises ont emboîté le
pas à la logique à la régie renault
départ en fanfare du rallye des brad est
organisée par la cgt aujourd'hui à paris
georges séguy et henri krasucki était la
place stalingrad pour le démarrage du
cortège une centaine de voitures
transportant des travailleurs de
certaines entreprises de la région
parisienne en difficulté d'autres
cortèges parfaite en même temps donnant
chalon bordeaux ils ont tous rendez-vous
à saint-etienne jeudi prochain c'est
l'occasion pour les français de prendre
conscience de la gravité du problème du
chômage a dit monsieur krasucki la
hausse des prix souci numéro un des
français selon le baromètre mensuel
sofres figaro souci numéro également de
jean pierre fourcade le ministre des
finances il l'a répété ce matin au
ministre qui a assisté à la conférence
de l'oscd eux le redémarrage de
l'inflation le retour à des tendances
protectionnistes dans certains pays les
états unis en particulier d'un kg est a
dit le ministre des finances
c'est d'autant plus grave que les
démocraties industrielles n'ont pas su
profiter de la période de récession pour
résoudre les problèmes de la hausse des
prix est bien arrivé à athènes stop
voyage sans problème stop c'est sans
doute le télégramme pour envoyer à leurs
familles les 297 réfugiés qui ont quitté
beyrouth à bord d'un bateau américain
pas de naissance n'est pas de décès à
bord a dit d'un voyageur mais un bal
improvisé grâce à l' orchestre du navire
les américains ont tout fait pour que
cette croisière soit agréable les états
unis pourrait recommencer une telle
opération dit on à washington car il
reste un millier de citoyens américains
ou big bang en ce moment
enfin un spectacle exceptionnel aux
bermudes pour le départ de la course du
bicentenaire des grands voiliers
il ne s'agit plus cette fois deux
navigateurs solitaires mais au contraire
d'embarcations de prestige de la marine
à voile un peu de précipitation et
beaucoup de maladresses ont quand même
failli provoquer un drame
au départ tous les bateaux voulait
prendre le vent en même temps résultat
cette collision dont deux très graves
qui ont obligé les équipages à rentrer
au port
en particulier ceux quatre mâts espagnol
qui a cassé un de ces mâts
avec leur le couloir leurs heures de
pointe et leurs heures creuses les
métros de toutes les grandes villes du
monde ont toujours été le terrain de
prédilection des voyous le phénomène est
particulièrement sensible aux etats-unis
ou à certaines heures le métro est un
véritable coupe gorge car la violence
qui s'est installée dans la rue est
descendu tout naturellement sous terre
la france n'échappe pas à ce phénomène
aux escaliers du métro où ça trocadéro
en descendant il m'en tape raté par le
cou et par la figure par longtemps et je
poussais décrit comme les régions du
monde arrivé j'étais combien si ce qui
est ainsi d'une vingtaine d'années et
nous ont dit quelque chose
et oui j'ai peur j'ai peur alors j'ai
poussé des cris des intimes on dit cela
mais ils vous ont dit ce qu'ils
voulaient oui oui l'hymne au stade il en
aurait plus de tirs et de les menacer et
juges du monde d'arriver et se sont
sauvés 348 station 57 kilomètres de
couloirs 4 million et demi de voyageurs
par jour le monde souterrain du métro
est une véritable échelle réduite du
monde de surface de l'exhibitionniste
aux pickpockets il a de tout temps
abriter une faune marginal assuré dans
la plupart des cas d'agir en toute
impunité
aujourd'hui le phénomène a pris une
ampleur inquiétante même la resquille
qui se veut souvent visible presque
provocante
regardez ces garçons quelques instants
auparavant il était passé régulièrement
avec leur ticket mais en voyant la
caméra ils nous ont demandé de les
filmer en train de resquiller c'est plus
facile de passer
en fraude maintenant qu'avant il est
pensionnaire les poinçonneurs ont
disparu avec la force de dissuasion
qu'il représentait la modernisation du
métro a conduit la régie à supprimer
progressivement certains postes
aujourd'hui on ne rencontre plus
d'employés sur les quais et 100 stations
fonctionnent avec un seul agent isolé
dans son bureau pour certains cette
déshumanisation a des conséquences
beaucoup plus graves qu'une joyeuse
envolé de lycéens par dessus des
tourniquets délits sur le métro délire
bien fournit d'ailleurs qui sont livrés
je veux parler des quais qui sont livrés
à de véritables bandes organisées
connue de nous d'ailleurs connu de nous
et de la police qui sévissent à new day
jour partiellement le soir
particulièrement pendant les week-ends
et qui envahissent les rames de métro
qui rançonnent en provoquant des
bousculades qui rançonnent à légiférer
nous sommes bien que le problème de la
violence de l'agressivité n'est pas un
phénomène propre au métro c'est un
phénomène de la société avec tout ce qui
s'y passe mais nous sommes persuadés que
les mesures prises par la direction à
savoir la raréfaction du personnel sont
qu'une prime d'encouragement constitue
un encouragement cette agressivité tenus
par des impératifs économiques la
direction n'a pas le même langage
s'il est vrai dit elle que la
modernisation en plaine la suppression
de certains postes il est faux
d'affirmer que la sécurité est une
affaire d'effectifs
même si la régie a son propre service de
surveillance il ne lui appartient pas de
maintenir l'ordre dans l'enceinte du
métro la ratp n'a pas les n'a pas la
responsabilité de ce que je qualifierais
de délinquants ce qu'elle soit qu'elle
soit mineure ou qu'elle soit majeure
ce n'est pas bien évidemment qu'il se
désintéresse eu ce problème au contraire
c'est une de nos grandes
nos préoccupations mais en france et
lappartient a puissance publique
menés tout des mesures de prévention et
de répression de s'être délinquance
au-delà de la polémique direction
syndicats qui invoque tour à tour la
qualité du service rendu la défense du
consommateur la défense de l'emploi et
les données économiques
il reste l'appréhension que ressentent
ce voyageur ou employés qui parcourt les
longs couloirs aux lumières blafardes
bien sûr il y à des stations puchot du
que d'autres la police les connaît et
concentre sur elle ses efforts
multiplication des patrouilles contrôles
d'identité chaque jour 800 policiers en
uniforme ou en civil s'efforce de
débusquer voyous des malfaiteurs mais
ils ne peuvent pas être partout à la
fois combien sont ils ceux qui ont été
agressés et qui ne l'ont pas fait savoir
les statistiques officielles ne
comptabilise que les agressions ayant
entraîné une plainte même si les
chiffres de cette année ne sont pas
supérieurs à ceux de l'année dernière
ils font apparaître trois fois plus
d'agressions qui lie à cinq ans d'où la
décision du préfet de police degrés à
partir du 1er octobre
des brigades spécialement affectés au
métro
jusqu'à présent la police travailler de
façon non pas aléatoire mais elle
essayait essentiellement de faire le
maximum de présence sur le terrain avec
un personnel certes très compétent mais
qui connaissait pas spécialement les
problèmes du métro je crois que la
décision du pld préfet de police va
permettre de spécialités sur nos
problèmes
un état major et un certain nombre
d'agents en uniforme qui connaîtront
tout particulièrement nos installations
notre personnel et fait dire également
le milieu délinquant qui se promène dans
le métro
cette police spéciale n'a de chances
d'être efficace que si elle couvre
l'ensemble du réseau
il faudrait alors 2700 policiers ce qui
paraît impossible
or si l'on se contente de surveiller les
points chauds on risque fort de déplacés
seulement le problème
aujourd'hui il a fait encore très chaud
du soleil un temps sec à part quelques
orages dans le sud et demain et bien
demain ce sera la même chose du soleil
mais aussi des nuages qui se
développeront dans l'après midi qui se
transformeront en orage ses nombreux des
pyrénées à la loire et aux alpes
c'est avec toute la rédaction d'antenne
2 que je vous souhaite une soirée bien
agréable
bonsoir si vous n'avez pas assisté à
l'intégralité de ce journal en voici les
principaux titres en exclusivité les
premières images de call à berlin et
fauconnier vous les reverrai à 23h30
edmond simeoni condamné à cinq ans de
prison dont deux avec sursis
italie démocrates-chrétiens et
communiste face à face
première journée britannique pour valéry
giscard d'estaing accueil cordial à
23h30 la dernière édition avec bernard
pradines ou